they say well
today's speaker is Barbara
apologists the Center for political
ecology in Santa Cruz her work explores
the linkages between culture power
environmental crisis and human rights
abuse dr. Johnson work examines the
driving force has been controlling
processes generating crisis and
inhibiting meaningful remedy her
research is action-oriented chronicled
in some 16 books among them water
culture power in 1997 very seminal work
kappa lies half-truths subtitle
confronting the radioactive legacies of
the Cold War in 2007 the consequential
damages of nuclear war in 2008 with one
major prize in addition to more than 125
articles she's led an interdisciplinary
effort to a circle Turnitin perspectives
in the UN Special River to investigation
on human rights in the environment she's
developed a keep reaching for the world
petition on dams she served as an expert
witness and researcher for the Marshall
Islands nuclear Claims Tribunal served
as US Representative to UNESCO ihp water
and cultural diversity advisory
committee served as an expert advisor to
the UN special repertoire for human
contamination in toxic waste
investigation continued human rights
abuse associated with nuclear weapons
testing by the United States and
Marshall Islands among the number of
other appointments including on hydro
development human rights abuses one mala
her work has been acknowledged by the
american anthropological association
with the
2002 kimball award for publishing
applied anthropology among many many
others her she has a bachelor's degree
from the University of California
Berkeley and a PhD from the University
of Massachusetts to after this pot there
will be an open discussion with students
which you're all invited to tomorrow
there is a presentation and open
discussion titled the precarious
hydrosphere the big picture on white
biocultural health matters from New the
130 and croon g19 so everybody please
join me thank you thank you Chris Thank
You Sadie Sadie has a sheet at her desk
that has a place where you can put your
name and your email because today's
remarks I have a summation of the major
points plus all of these resource links
and rather than cut down more trees I
think it makes sense to email you all a
document so sign up on that if you'd
like it and I just want to do is buy way
point of injury a few little bit more on
on Who I am like many of you I'm an
interdisciplinary am I have a master's
degree in environmental science before I
went off to get the the doctorate in
anthropology and when I got to
University of Massachusetts back when
dinosaurs still roam they said what do
you want to study and I said well I'm
here because you have a Caribbean
program oh yeah well one of our
professors is actually an in the loony
bin right now and the others just been
bumped up to provo so I had no one who
was my advisor which for me was awesome
I was an independent studies person I
was interested in that intersect between
environment and what was going on in
part because I started out after my
Berkeley degree working as a planner
doing environmental impact analysis and
long-range planning at the county of
santa clara in california and that meant
at the time that silicon valley was just
starting we didn't have that name then
and it was just starting to boom so as a
21 year old I was the kid who could go
up and say I'm sorry there are
archaeological resources here to a mafia
representative who was turning all of
their or
into tract homes I learned a lot about
power as a young agent decided that this
wasn't necessarily a world for me and
went back to grad school I've got the
Environmental Studies degree because I
wanted to know what was going on and why
and how did things change but especially
the bio physical long-term perspective
so I was interested in paleo ecology and
culture ecology the cultural creation of
drought in Caribbean islands where I was
living at the time I did it for fun I
knew I would never apply that master's
degree I was going to go on and get a
doctorate in anthropology anyhow and
they probably wouldn't count it the
interesting thing is that those science
courses that I took all of those years
ago in ecology everything paleo no
tropical ecology human ecology cultural
ecology biological college et cetera
ended up being one of the most important
at facets of my career because I have
one foot in the sciences and one foot in
the social sciences and i straddle that
divide so my first job I was hired out
of with my PhD teaching environmental
studies at Sac State and this was in the
late 1980s walls were falling right
literally and we had the this new
documentary phenomenon on on on public
television we just had the idea that you
had CNN had just come out that you had
satellite TV just came out so the world
started getting connected to what was
happening locally in a very different
way especially the rain forests are
burning satellite imagery showing for
the first time ever all of the burning
rain forests in Brazil and and so the
late 80s was a very heady time for
environmental activism the the nineteen
ninety day first one that was the
largest protests around the world to
date and it was a global protest over
environmental degradation around the
world the 1992 earth summit was the
culmination of a lot of this so this is
when I was teaching and teaching
environmental studies and very
frustrated that environmental studies at
that time dealt with human problems as
population and the problem but no death
no understanding of what human
conditions
of the of you know the varied
experiences and most importantly why
there's so many inequities in the world
this activism around Rio Sierra Club
Legal Defense Fund now known as Earth
justice brought a petition to the Human
Rights Council and said environment the
right to a healthy environment should be
a fundamental human right and they did
this just a couple months before Rio and
it captured the world's attention
because chico mendes who was an activist
in brazil and had been featured in a TV
in a documentary that went around the
world on satellite TV had recently been
murdered and the world's attention was
focused on not only rain forest burning
but the people and the plight of the
people that lived in these contexts and
their struggles so the right of a
healthy environment the way that they
responded at this convention was to
appoint a special report or the first
special repertoire of the human rights
then it was human rights commission to
explore what is the right to a healthy
environment and they put out a call
global call for contributions I saw that
call and at that point was interested in
writing my own textbook so I contacted
the main organizers Sierra Club Legal
Defense Fund and I said I'll trade you I
sit in anthropology and
interdisciplinary professional
organizations i have i'm connected to
these global networks of people who are
on the ground documenting the experience
from from a community perspective or an
interest group perspective I'll give you
that I'll help you get access to that
information you can share what you've
got so we agreed to collaborate it was
shocking at the time for this
un-sponsored study the notion of the
right to a healthy environment was
focused just on individuals and
individual rights the notion that only
individuals have rights and they are
being violated so that meant journalists
were thrown in jail because they
reported on where nuclear waste dumps
were in in Soviet Union for example was
the attention and the focus of it when
the environmental social sciences came
in it was anthropologist and geographers
and some ecologists and so forth
Ethne linguists and indigenous rights
organizations when we came into the
story and started pulling together the
study that I shared and coordinated it
was the first time that that the Special
Rapporteur and the Human Rights
Commission had considered that groups
have rights and that rights are being
abused not just by individuals we had a
complaint mechanisms in the
International Human Rights loss was
evolving but that complaint mechanism
was only focused on prosecuting
individuals even today you could
prosecute an individual for crimes
against humanity but you can't prosecute
those who profited for those crimes or
the banks that you know especially the
World Bank for example that might have
funded a project and created interest
and profited from that so the idea that
processes lead to human rights abuse
created by governments or international
governmental entities and that groups
have rights are being violated was new
and that was something that we were
putting forth we put out a study called
who pays the price the social cultural
context of environmental crisis and this
tells you how long ago it was because
the imagery is so blurred and our photos
were really poor back then Island Press
eventually published this in 1994 and it
was the first environmental social
science text that nonprofit science
oriented publishing house in ever put
out more importantly though we put out
reports in 1991 threw 93 annual reports
that went to the UN and that helped
inform and support the positions the
rapid tour was taking but we also I got
a grant from the Nathan Cummings
foundation to produce we took five of
the most egregious nasty disgusting
cases so obvious demonstrating these
points that groups have rights that
processes like militarism and
development we're responsible and and
and that there was this culpability gap
a huge culpability gap so this booklet
was funded and we and we sent out four
hundred and fifty copies by mail to all
of the top human rights organizations in
the world all of the top environmental
organizations in the world and then to
all of the foundations and that pushed
and created a sea change in the notion
that human
an environment actually were connected
after that foundation started funding
these issues and these organizations
started morphing and evolving and
changing to look at those intersects so
it was really interesting we also had
thanks to American Anthropological
Association then had a congressional
fellowship program and and our member in
1992 Greg button was a staffer to
Senator wellstone he died a sadly of
about two years after this but he was
pushing through Congress this new bill
on the right to a healthy environment
and he died in the process of forming
this bill it sort of languished when
Clinton came in he signed it in as an
executive order that's why we have
environmental justice on the map in the
United States and so forth at any rate
Greg button managed to get into the
every member of the incoming Congress in
1992 got our booklet on who pays the
price the social cultural context of
environmental crisis and that was in
there welcome to Congress here are the
issues packet which shows you the power
of having a well-placed individual at a
given time I also published the whole
report distilled down into this book and
sent it to the White House took al gore
to Kathleen McGinty was head of the
Environmental Quality White House
Council on Environmental Quality al gore
read it and he used it in his
reorganizing government and sent it to
EPA and said we need to make this
approach as a centerpiece community
community approach government's role
should be to help communities empower
communities to identify define and
address their problems this is where I
learned some of the the differences
between what I'm pushing for and how it
might be received in the sense of beware
what you asked because way it gets
interpreted at least within the clinton
ministration the way it was interpreted
this approaches it's actually in the
federal government's interests for
communities to take ownership of their
problems because before then the federal
government was responsible for paying
and providing the technical expertise
and so forth in especially in the
context of EPA Superfund site cleanup
and so forth so it was a way of reducing
the federal obligation and
creasing state and local obligation mind
you with good intentions but but some of
the outcomes again are beware what you
ask for so that was sort of my point in
pulling this together we wanted to come
up with the most egregious cases to make
the hello this is out there the poster
child cases if you will one of the most
egregious cases was the lingering
consequences nuclear weapons testing and
the whole new key nuclear fuel cycle
change be that or uranium mining
processing milling production and
manufacturing of weapons but also all of
the energy infrastructure needed to do
that use and then of course the the
consequences so I'm going to switch more
intense almera like talking out or just
talk about this one of many cases that
that we pulled together and and and
pushed in these in this initiative after
dropping of the bomb of course the world
did not see these photos but but the for
many years but the US came in shortly
after they they seized journalists
photos and files who were on the ground
especially in Nagasaki and that became
long buried in the classified bowels of
government but they contacted the
Manhattan scientists that they couldn't
as soon as they could they got him to
Japan to walk around and help document
so one of the key Matt Manhattan
scientists that had been working in
Rochester at the time James Neal was
brought out as part of this team but
also with a couple of the ahead by all
the biologists and doctors that were
looking at human effects of radiation
during World War two and they went and
took pictures and they interviewed folks
and then they they said gee whiz there's
a whole lot more to this atomic field
than just a blast and just radiation
which is what they had predicted
radiation causes would blast something
you know burn your skin initially
incinerate you and then that's what this
document says radiation burns but also
and not just the devastation from the
force they started recognizing
especially after talking to the Japanese
doctors of these rate of the radiation
diseases and sickness that was already
immediately in
right so they came up with an approach
to fund through the National Research
Council the Department of what was the
equivalent Department of Defense back
then the US government funded through
the National Research Council an atomic
bomb casualty commission and the purpose
of the atomic bomb casualty commission
in the explicit classified version was
to document to study and document the
human effects of radiation not to treat
the world was presented to the world was
that the u.s. was going to facilitate an
assist in in Japan and with the Japanese
living in inhuman Nagasaki and more
broadly expected was that with all of
these doctors coming in setting up
hospitals and labs that people would be
treated they just a little word of
context allotment I'll get to it later
at the same time they're studying the
human of health effects in Japan they
needed to understand clearly not only
the power of this but demonstrate it to
the world so they set up in 1946 tests
in the Marshall Islands which was at the
Protectorate it was a islands of Japan
had been occupying during World War two
the US came through it was an occupied
territory by the US military at the time
a year later after these tests the
United Nations gave them trust territory
status to the United States so at the
time they were just a nation and they
did they took all the remnants of the
world war two fleet from the Pacific
region they also brought some ships in
from the Atlantic German boats and they
put him in the bikini lagoon and they
did to to a brawl so brought in
representatives United Nations and from
27 different countries including the
Soviet Union on these boats I think it's
something like over 27,000 people on
boats to observe and so the world could
see the power of this weapon for
themselves and so that was in part the
early Cold War you know this is what we
got you know back off but also what they
didn't expect they did an above
atmosphere shot and then they did a
subsurface shot this is the subsurface
shot and this you can see one of the
ships going up into it what it did was
it atomized the whole coral Lagoon right
and that went up and it also transformed
as it
mice into this massive dense wet cloud
that then dropped all of this heavy very
radioactive debris over all of the
remaining ships that weren't destroyed
in the detonation they overnight or
immediately managed to decimate the
entire pacific fleet and then they had
all of these folks who are watching
observing and the poor soldiers who were
or military personnel who were supposed
to go out and clean up and make these
boats useful again months and months and
months years actually trying to
decontaminate this is where they learned
that radiation and the properties of
radiation was so much more profound than
understood anything with a carbon-based
structure it adheres to and transform so
if you have a metal on your boat iron
for example that you're walking on
afterwards you have radio iron it's no
longer just iron Fe it is a radioactive
isotope of iron so if you're walking on
that boat they found that they that you
know the idea there in the Pacific six
degrees above the equator people want to
wear shorts go barefoot etc so all kinds
it was not uncommon that people were
getting see-through than you know their
their skin burns but also at night
people were glowing in some cases some
documented cases just by walking on
these decks so they learn that that
atomic warfare is a real messy
enterprise and we need to do a whole lot
more science they the atomic bomb casual
decommissioned started structuring the
human health effects component of it the
Marshall Islands was designated as a
specific proving ground and that's where
they studied the ecological effects as
well as the human effects on this is
James neon right here who set up a
pregnancy outcome study five years they
if you wanted to get food rations in
this part of Japan you had to sign up
for and be part of these studies if
you're a woman if you're pregnant or
just had a baby you couldn't get food
unless you signed up for the study and
that meant that you went in and you got
documented and they took samples and
they took did ethnographic interviews as
well because James Neal believe that
that radiation and it had no problem in
terms of genetic effects he had a
natural history degree studying fruit
flies everyone was concerned that
radiation would have this massive
genetic effect but his premise was that
that other factors are greater in
potentially delivering the effect and
those other factors include cultural
factors such as marrying your cousin he
was a huge Enox scientist and he
believed that and afterwards after World
War Two they called it genetics this
early field of genetics that if you
married your first second or third
cousin and this was one of the questions
in the in the Japanese pregnancy study
then any offspring has a higher
potential to have congenital defect
because of that relationship at a
genetic level then because of the
radiation exposure so they pulled
together the study every single person
is you can see the mass data collections
was was counted in it kids and families
and so forth were documented and
assessed they also studied things like
what was happening with babies and
children as they grew they took x-rays
of their long bones physical
anthropologists helped come to interpret
that some of the things they documented
was that radiation and atmospheric
radiation from these tests creates a lot
of strontium and that strong jian
actually adheres to the bone and it was
causing major stunting in japan meaning
children that were exposed at high
levels we're not growing to the
potential height that their siblings or
families but also mental stunting as
well as physical stunting the scientists
that documented that submitted his
report and it was classified and
censored in it and he believed it would
stop any future nuclear weapons testing
and in fact because of censorship it did
not so you can see some of the tests
that they were doing and as I said they
went to the Marshall Islands at the same
time to establish the Pacific proving
grounds 46 was the demonstration test by
48 they had their first rounds of of
next-generation weapons in 48 in in 51
and 52 any time they did nuclear weapons
tests in the northern atolls they
evacuated people I just wanted to give
you a sense
Marshallese map Marshall Islands anyone
been there well was off the map actually
from from 1946 well and and in a big way
from 1958 all the way until 1973 when
EPA was created and they first got
access to the islands Marshallese were
not allowed to leave without approval of
the United States government and no one
was allowed to go in and it was one of
those like a secret city and you had
secret cities in Chernobyl you know in
the Soviet Union you also had secret
territories in the Pacific so you when I
was brought out and this is an aside in
in 1999 contacted to facilitate an
investigation with the nuclear claims
tribunal in the Marshall Islands I went
to usgs to try and get maps for the
nation and I was told they're still
classified I couldn't get access to maps
the USGS had created so it was really
interesting however what is the place
twelve hundred or so islands 22 Act
holes and act all is coral reef with
little Sam's spit on highest elevation
in the nation's eight feet except for
the two-story buildings on the capital
island yet these are the master
navigators of the world you have people
living there for ten thousand years with
this in an area the size of Mexico with
tiny dots of sand and palm trees right
and mostly it's a water world and people
from the northern chain all the way down
to the southern chain think again of the
stretch of Mexico speak the same
language ten thousand years of being
there it's because they are the
navigators they use outriggers they're
the ones who are now causing a
reinvigoration of that ancient art of
navigating by the stars and the winds
and the currents and using an outrigger
to get around in the Pacific so that is
a map that they make to show you where
where where are you in the Marshall
Islands of course when you're living in
those places you're living in
water-stressed areas no rivers lakes
streams none in all of the Marshall
Islands you have little brackish ponds
from rainwater and and sometimes you'll
have a well that you can tap into with
brackish water atop the salt water lens
underneath these coral islands most of
the water comes from coconut or fish
from what you eat so that's a no
dimension as it turns out everything you
make is from what course what you have
around you which means your mats your
clothing in traditional times meaning up
until World War two really your clothing
was made from fibers from the plants
that grew around you you're cooking with
the coconut hulls so nuclear weapons
tests the first hydrogen bomb in 52 was
tested there the u.s. assured with each
of these tests if it came out the 52
tests were illustrated in Life Magazine
not until nineteen fifty four but they
assured the world whenever any outcry
came up in the United Nations that the
people in the Marshall Islands are fine
they're safe there is no fall out there
are no injuries that this is a
controlled process that what you can do
a bomb up into the air or drop a bomb
and the and the release goes up and they
thought of the atmosphere is like the
ocean the solution to pollution is
dilution if you put it up in the
atmosphere it we diluted around in the
world and you won't have to worry Bravo
tests changed their thinking Bravo test
was march first 1954 and it was the
dirtiest detonation the US has ever done
and by far the dirtiest nuclear disaster
to date including Fukushima and it was a
subsurface blast it was purposefully
designed as a thermonuclear weapon to be
as dirty as possible because one of the
scientific questions they were asking in
this lab of theirs how big of a city can
we wipe out how big of an area can we
wipe out they had monitors throughout
the inane documenting where did fallout
go and fallout went to raid to populated
tolls it turns out in 1999 and they
finally acknowledged that the whole
nation was carpeted with with lethal
levels of or near lethal levels of
fallout so this is a boy who was exposed
because he was outside running across
the reef when fallout cloud came over
and he's from wrong a lot once they
realized whole populations had been
dangerously exposed the first
recognition being whether men posted in
the area they evacuated the Weathermen
and then
day and a half later came and evacuated
the people are wrong a lot they also
evacuated nearby at all ettrick they
decided the people of liq yep and
another at ho also horribly exposed that
there was too many to fit on a belt so
they left them there and they left them
in the contaminated environment so the
people in ettrick and the people wrong a
lot were taken to Kwajalein and a top
secret study was initiated project 4.1
which looked at the human effects over
time meaning 30 days 60 days 90 days
three month period and then they decided
to keep wrangle up there and study them
for three more years who Turk was
returned to their at home meanwhile at
the same time the 1954 study the
pregnancy study in in Japan they were
pulling together their data and they
came out with massive evidence of
congenital defects of early termination
and so forth but they were able to say
it when all was said and done no
statistical relevance because any any
evidence from someone who was had a
first second or third degree it was a
product of first second or third degree
marriage was tossed out the other reason
they were able to throw it out was
because the the or just discount was
because the there was these artificial
notions to their study they said here's
the blast zone they drew a little map
and and if you were outside of the blast
zone that we don't have to worry because
they didn't understand or recognize
fallout right it was just in the blossom
and they compared as a good control
study should they used as a comparative
population from the town of querer now I
went to her oshima a couple years ago
and I went on top of the hotel with my
husband to have a martini and look out
the window and say oh my god we believe
we're doing this and see there's the bay
and I can see curiae this control city
from where I'm sitting I went back to
the fallout maps and you can see that
this is right there right there so they
had flawed samplings in their controls
so the study came up with a whole host
of issues that were identified which
they said was not necessarily statistic
relevant they did notice at a
statistical level changes in the
male-female ratio meaning that
reproductive effects were documented
even at that level but they decided
we're not going to look at this in the
Marshall Islands so they set up this
study in the Marshall Islands and the
initial study that then was discussed in
1958 in this high level classified
conference beta burns lost a hair
depressed red cell and leukocyte counts
flu-like symptoms nausea fingernail
discoloration radioactivity in the urine
changes at the cellular level in blown
blood and bone marrow all of that which
we understand to be precursors in things
like leukemias and a whole host of other
cancers now we understand this in
hindsight they also decided we need to
do more study and we have this great
wonderful controlled population living
on an island it's the perfect laboratory
they while though the people are wrong
the lap were being studied between 1954
and 1958 they did more nuclear weapons
tests that the atmospheric ban passed it
finally in 1958 and they did literally
almost one or two tests a day during 58
to try and get as much information and
data as they could before that
atmospheric ban would go into effect so
you had massive amounts as if you had
one who rose from a bomb every day for
the whole from 1946 to 1958 I mean
massive amounts of radiation coming up
into the atmosphere and into the local
level fallouts they documented not in
the radiation ecology studies not only
fallout and its movement through the
through the soil and through plants the
bioaccumulation in certain kinds of
plants but also to the not only
terrestrial creatures but the the marine
so fish clams crabs the marine from
shame so despite a recommendation from
the from the medical doctors who were
studying the health effects to not let
the people rangga lap get any more
exposure to radiation they had already
been more exposed in any other living
population on the planet they return
them to their heavily irradiated
environment in in late nineteen
fifty-seven and they were there while
they did another
round of tests through 58 of course
people in marshall islands were not
informed about any of this about they
didn't even understand nuclear or the
term radiation what that meant until
1973 one EPA came and educated them in
the long term study they set up they had
doctors come to the Marshall Islands
initially once a year and then once
twice a year and they came out with with
ships and and they've had a cement line
lead-lined caverns so that they could
assess your radiation they monitored
blood they took blood samples and bone
marrow samples of children if you were
in the wrong of that population they
also identified control subjects that
were matched at the same age people who
were forced from ma jiro for example the
capital island to participate in these
studies as little kids because they
matched the age they initially were
looking for things like they were
wondering about diabetes because of
those red blood cell changes that I
mentioned earlier earlier with project
4.1 they were recognizing that diabetes
and metabolic disorders and heart
problems were all related and perhaps
that was what was happening would happen
here and while they documented that what
surprised them was that they found by
1973 population-wide nodules and fired
cancers so the first identification
relationship between radioiodine and its
effects on the thyroid and cancer came
because of their experience this dr.
canard who was the head of the study he
had a friends in Michigan where his home
base was who excuse me his home base was
in Brookhaven but he had friends in
Michigan who were a pharmaceutical
company coming up with how do we develop
a hormone substitute for for thyroid so
that we can help treat this in the event
of nuclear problems or radiation
accidents in the United States so they
tested it on the Marshallese one of many
opportunistic tests that occurred over
the years for just here's our population
let's figure it out and again without
without any informed consent without
any consent without any knowledge what
was happening people thought they were
being treated by doctors and that was
for their health they it was not at all
clear and they would come into clinic
and when I went through all the the Sun
I went through all of the declassified
documents and all of the letters and
complaints when the scientists were
often that they come up with all of
their runny noses and they expect us to
treat you know medical conditions I've
you know and so how are we going to
handle this how we're going to keep them
happy the long-term study look at this
list of what the long-term study
documented because it is immense
basically the major conditions that are
facing humanity today immune deficient
diseases metabolic disorders like
diabetes in fact you have the highest
rates in the Pacific and one of the
highest rates in the world of diabetes
in the Marshall Islands now growth
impairment and children that stunting I
was talking about cancers especially
thyroid and leukemia were identified in
the first several decades now it's it's
a whole host hypertension heart disease
premature aging they had a whole study
focused on premature aging and that
includes things like crumbling bones in
an early age you know changes in your
connective tissues so you have you it
hurts to walk around and so forth as
well as cataracts and and and
degenerative osteoarthritis miscarriages
congenital birth defects anytime any
woman gave birth to a monster baby they
called them the the scientists would fly
in or they would require local
practitioners to collect the child out
outer island which meant a boat several
days go out dig it up if it's not if
it's not alive and take it back as lab
samples horrific horrific history all
classified what does that mean in terms
of science it means our understanding of
radiation health effects was stunted if
you will by this immense amount of
research that was done yet it was not
used to inform or shape public health
policy let alone medical science center
ship the Marshall Islands allowed the
suffering too you know you know they're
suffering allowed an expansion of the
militarism around the world and this map
shows you it does not show you the North
Korea tests
so it's up to date up to the North Korea
tests but it shows you this was a global
expansion of where people tested and as
it turns out the experiences in the
Marshall Islands were also being
reproduced in Kazakhstan where the
Soviet Union had similar human subject
populations and we've just found out
because france just to classified
comparable databases in december in in
Polynesia and in algeria so with with
censorship you will have the means for a
halt well organized an orchestrated
campaign to pacify the public in the
united states and through the united
states control of the International
Atomic Age inner energy agency they were
able to pass this along to the world the
notions that we can understand and
control the health effects if you have
the knowledge you can build your own
fallout shelter you can protect yourself
that there are that a concrete wall is
sufficient to protect yourself the lived
experience in the Marshall Islands
demonstrated otherwise and continues to
demonstrate EPA came in as I said a
couple times in 73 they came in later a
group to help and educate as Peace Corps
workers teaching them and for example
some Marshallese English and how to read
and write and decipher for themselves so
by the late 70s they were asking the
Department of Energy representatives
than it was the first was Atomic Energy
Commission that was Department of Energy
to evacuate them again art would they
understood their [ __ ] was
contaminated and that the everyone was
getting sick and some people were dying
and that these things were related to
their exposures the government refused
because they thought it sent a wrong
message to the world that was just
starting to grow nuclear energy so they
refused to evacuate them Greenpeace came
through in 1985 and spent some time on
the island and then helped them on the
Greenpeace Rainbow Warrior ship evacuate
to the southern part of the nation the
next stop on their chain was New Zealand
where that ship was blown up again this
is 80s and protests over nuclear
militarism but also protests over
expansion of nuclear energy
this is um from data declassified in
1999 just looking at radioiodine so I'd
I'm 131 so you're big big huge block
that's Marshall Islands here's all the
iodine 131 released in at the Nevada
Test Site here's Chernobyl here's
Hanford operations so it gives you just
a little sense I was looking for data
update this graph for Fukushima but it's
still ongoing and so it's very difficult
it's also been at a concerted level at
me within the United States and thus the
IAEA we're not going there we're not
going to collect and amass the global
data the way we did during the Cold War
that allowed with with with global mom
air air quality monitors and so forth
that kind of data collection because of
that first study that I did way back
when we looked at this wrong collab case
and we included it in when we sent the
booklet out into Congress in 1993
shortly after that journalist came out
with a sensational story about human
subjects experimentation in the United
States during the Cold War it was the
first time we had heard and it caused
this huge outcry that humans were
injected plutonium and other sorts of
radioisotopes for in part for gee whiz
science to figure out what's going on
with no informed consent with no consent
knowledge of what was going on and many
of them died so that sensational story
prompted when Clinton came in a excuse
me he was in office at the creation of
advisory commission on human radiation
experimentation of which one of your
former professors now deceased cots k
ATZ was a key actor in he's a
bioethicist and a medical doctor here at
yale and he was also a member of the
Tuskegee in experiment commission his
papers here are in your yellow archive
and in those papers are many of these
declassified documents that demonstrate
sort of this history so that so the
Advisory Commission went through all of
this stuff initially on it on a mandate
that said let's just look at the United
States and its behavior during World War
two and let's just look at that meant
the Continental 1948 States because of
outcry from other places like the
territory of alaska right
because it wasn't estate then and and
all of the world war two human
experimentation and nuclear testing
there but also the later cold war-era
nuclear testing there it was expanded to
include alaska and puerto rico where it
turns out we did a massive array of
human subject experimentation on
biological chemical warfare as well as
radiation and because of my story which
i sent to barbara boxer she sent to that
to the head of the hazel O'Leary who was
head of the energy commission they got
the Marshall Islands included in it so
it was one of those unintended
ramifications of a study right done way
back when then I was contacted after
this Commission comes out and nothing
happens in the Marshall Islands except
for more declassified documents and a
very limited you know what do we do with
this knowledge they had a tribunal set
up because that when they were given
independence under Ronald Reagan he said
hey I'll trade you you can be
independent and we wash our hands of any
obligation from the damages from nuclear
weapons testing in exchange will give
you a hundred and fifty million dollars
and help you set up an administrative
court to administer that for damages if
conditions change your new information
comes to light you have the power to go
back to Congress so after reagan signed
that agreement they set up this Tribunal
they contacted me to do the wrong
elapsed story to document the
consequential damages I did as an
anthropologist I got ethnographers and a
whole host of other folks to go out and
do Island by Island questionnaires on
what was your traditional way of life
what was life like before this occur
what kinds of changes to jubes or what
is your way of life like now so that we
could get at more deeper questions than
just radiation health effects but
damages that included loss of a way of
life loss of a healthy way of life loss
of life thanks to the declassified
documents which by that point were word
searchable on the computer I was able to
go back and pull every single document
that had natives for example as a key
term or a term embedded anywhere in the
text we demonstrated we did this massive
report and we did a three day hearing
and in the nuclear claims tribunal in
2001 where for the first time the
tribunal of three
just two of which were American could
hear the whole their whole experience of
the case or a claim or an injury in
historical context it's also the first
time the whole nation and got to listen
because it was broadcast by radio the
story what happened in wrong about at
that time 19 9 2001 you did not have in
the curriculum any of this nuclear
weapons test so many kids had grown up
gone through schools never had any sense
of this nuclear history and at that time
the u.s. still controlled the curriculum
for the school system so again very
recent stuff so some of the things that
we documented are well known in common
now but it was the first time it was
hurt in the Marshall Islands in terms of
how fallout acts in the food chain how
it moves through the food chain in the
human body but the fact that the
Marshallese were the reasons we
understand that and that they were used
purposefully and exposed settings to
document the fact that chronic exposure
to low level radiation does more to
increase the risk of developing cancers
was one of the major outcomes and
reasons why the u.s. does not want to
acknowledge the validity of the study or
address at least different
administrations have different positions
I have my as an aside my notes from this
talk in addition to the resources link
so you can get a lot of this data and
detail the the tribunal hearing prompted
protests in the Marshall Islands it also
prompted broader concern it was as it
was evidence that that it wasn't just
you exposed because you receive fallout
from a blast or from a nuclear power
plant fallout for example but that two
or three generations later you're still
seeing the kinds of adverse health
outcomes that result that that
demonstrate genetic effects result from
living in a contaminate environment but
also demonstrate genetic effects because
two or three generations later the
really hot isotopes have degraded so
hearings periodically been held in
Congress as conditions have changed and
new information has come to light and
they have the right to go back to
Congress to request more resources this
Marshallese in 2005 in that picture was
part of the congressional record
but nothing no action has taken place
this was during the Bush administration
and their their response to Marshall
easy as 50 years is enough there is no
the only evidence that is valid on
radiation health effects is a health
physics approach that says external
exposures are our main concern and the
primary isotopes that chi ha cause high
exposure have been degraded by this time
in terms of their half lives and and as
an aside climate change is happening the
sea levels are rising the solution to
pollution is dilution you will all be
underwater soon what's the point so that
was the Bush administration's you know
Cavalier under under the table aside
that position has been embraced by the
Obama administration as well meanwhile
through this history as i said the
nuclear weapons testing in the
censorship allowed the growth in a
largely uncritically question in terms
of the science the real power and means
to question it because the
classification that occurred here and in
soviet union and so forth and the lack
of access to this information so it
wasn't until we got in a global
telecommunications and especially
computer and internet that we were able
to move to a whole nother level of
understanding this depth protest this is
a protest in japan which unfortunately
in my original slide was backwards but
it says no nukes and this was on TV that
went around the world sort of thing i
love that one so protests over over the
periodic and regular releases of tritium
for example are easily countered when
the bulk of information on the long-term
effects of a low-level radiation has
been kept out of the limelight for
decades and decades and the
authoritative voice in terms of Atomic
Energy Commission both in the nations
around the world and IAEA is controlled
Fukushima changed things obviously and
it continues to change things this map
was created by the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission about a week after Fukushima
so this if there I am on the west coast
you know 48 hours I know what's coming
my way just because of my knowledge i
call up right after Fukushima happens
the California Department of Energy and
say are you monitoring no we don't need
to
call up EP a federal are you monitoring
no we don't need to it's not a problem
no no no no so this was known coming but
it turns out and I went to the National
Archives to confirm this that the
national disaster radiological disaster
plan first disaster plan the US ever
created was for radiological disaster
the first number one thing control
information pacify the public because
the primary threat from a radiological
accident is public response fear social
unrest economic meltdown so the number
one thing control and pacify and that's
who this day is still the primary
response the the aside to that is the
notion that most of the injuries
associated from a radiological incident
can be attributed to psychosocial
processes and behavior your fear is what
creates your disease being the act of
fact citizen science has been again
because of telecommunications and access
to things like iphone apps turning with
a little plug in device your iphone into
a radiation geiger counter so citizen
science and access to information has
been the counter narrative and the
really exciting dimension post-fukushima
they took down a government by going out
and mapping uh-uh look at this hot spot
look at this hot spot no fukushi
fukushima is there and tokyo is exposed
they their citizen science was huge in
political transformation it was also a
big lesson to the united states and in
terms of again the control the message
and and make sure that you don't get to
that point this is a 2012 update map
I've yet to see one for 2013 showing you
the the releases in the ocean one of the
reasons why I do this is because the
Marshallese studies what was so
important we're not only the radiation
ecology of how it moves through the
environment and food chain and human
body but also through the marine chain
and so some of the studies we did was
map that radiation persist quite a long
time not only because of the way you can
bioaccumulate ER or heavy deposits would
adhere to coral in the reefs and things
like that but also because they
recognize there are these
chris streams in incurrence in in the
ocean so you can have a very contained
intense stream as it moves across the
Pacific and we're seeing evidence of
that in terms of now and in the future
of fish of specialty of kelp and sea
food products but basically i think that
the political response has been well
it's the genies out of the bottle
there's nothing we can do to control it
let's just adjust and adapt and move on
so all of this history prompted the
United Nations from various forces and
escalated because of Fukushima to
appoint a special report or this
category of special operators Jesco that
he exposes a number of them is
environmental contamination and toxic
waste came out of the initial rio
conference that that concern but it's
the first time the united nations human
rights council ever investigated nuclear
weapons or nuclear disaster ever and it
was the first time the united states in
that context also of course was was
examined so his his investigation not
well publicized in the united states
i'll bet you didn't hear about it he
went to the Marshall Islands and he went
to the United States and he took my book
in all of our documents and came up with
a report that was presented last
september's to the united nations human
rights council who heard and by
consensus adopted his report it was the
first time that the Marshallese were
ever to go ever able to go the united
nations human rights council and say
here's our problems again because they
were a secret off the map and because us
controlled all their movements during
the time of testing they wrote letters
but they were not allowed to leave and
go testify I got them there I went and
applied to a number of the foundations
that had funded my work over the years
documenting the history and the
consequential damages of that history
and they said I'm sorry but but this
information threatens not approved all
the way past the project director level
and it was the advisory board of the
foundations that nixed it and these are
a couple of very well known very
publicized nuclear foundations
foundations that publish support nuclear
work
that that my work and bringing the
Marshallese story to the UN at this
point is too damaging to the vested
interests of their board members who
have in invested in nuclear energy and
the sense that nuclear energy is the the
solution for climate change and
especially the Obama administration and
its various politics on this issue so I
didn't get any funding um I went around
and requested a few emergency grants
from foundations that bring the United
Nations you know people the United
Nations indigenous peoples Women's Fund
for global Human Rights was very helpful
there but mostly I crowd-sourced I did
an online you know Kickstarter IndieGoGo
kind of equivalent and send it all to my
note friends and family have a big
family so that was like one third of the
donations and then my colleagues and
they send it to their friend anyone who
had used our books over the years that
sort of thing so we got enough money to
cover travel to go to Geneva for a week
fifteen thousand dollars for five people
just for the travel and a place to stay
in a bite to eat begging for cheap or
free you know places to stay it was
pretty amazing and they then they were
able to present their issues in a
two-minute statement the Human Rights
Council but then also we did these side
events so this is side events on Human
Rights impact of the new club nuclear
weapons and what was really cool about
this was that it was not just the
Marshallese stories the first time the
Marshallese got to meet in this kind of
venue with other nuclear nations such as
Kazakhstan so this was a session on that
honor the test sites in there and their
effects in in Kazakhstan the Soviet
Union era and we also had people there
from Australia we had you know from a
number of different parts of the world
what was interesting in the discussion
as to who made comments and who accepted
the reporters report and recommendation
that said that the u.s. still has a
remaining obligation and liability and
that there are fundamental protracted
intergenerational human rights
consequences of living in a nuclear
disaster zone what was interesting was
that a 160 nations have no nuclear
weapons and no nuclear power in that
group that's where all of the comments
okay algeria because they just learned
that they had hosted it cuba no surprise
you know but also australia because they
wanted to be elected to the Security
Council and they were being pushed and
prodded by the other Pacific nations to
support it so you know so behind the
scenes politics none of the nuclear
weapons States none of the nuclear
weapons States made any positive
statement on it the only negative was
the United States because and they had
to respond because they were being
investigated and none of the nuclear
power states not a single one came out
on the record on this history now mind
you the wrong collapse story is what
prompted the initial test ban treaty so
historically the reason we have a peace
sign comes from the nuclear protests in
initially in London against nuclear
nuclear weapons so this historically
plays a big role in in in nuclear
militarism and advocacy but also
environmental action and yet it was all
silent very amazing all of this to say
on that unintended consequences be where
you ask for while the special report or
sport is amazing powerful and a lot of
it coming out of my work which was
gratifying it hasn't been implemented
and instead it what happened what are
the reasons why all silent on the US
front and especially on the media front
was that the timing of this was the Bush
versus what was his name who he was he
running against anything 2012 you know
and um they didn't want to have a
discussion in the presidential campaign
but also it turns out that was the week
Obama was scheduled to announce to the
world or to the united states that he
was approving changes in the epa over
permissibility levels for radiation in
the event of a radiation disaster and so
they suppress that they realize this is
bad timing there might be outcry over
the the Marshall Islands and their
experience with radiation hello so they
suppress it came out quietly in april
2013 i don't know if any of you heard or
notice or took notice but what has been
proposed and because of an executive
order is now in effect so they still
have a public comment period actually
just finished
weeks ago and it hasn't been officially
approved but it's already been effect
since 2013 April is changes in EPA's
permissibility level that say we do that
what is the science and what are the
standards and it raises it further even
greater than what Japan post-fukushima
has in terms of here's the critical
level 4 48 iodine-131 for example in
drinking water prior to april 2013 and
then these are the proposed levels
depending on which one they go for which
shows you and what it means is is we're
redefining this is strong geum we're
redefining our notions on the order of
not only a hundred times or thousand
times in some cases a hundred thousand
times more radiation is permissible and
we've redefining also the notice of the
definition of radiation disaster so it's
not just a nuclear weapons dirty bomb by
a terrorists or a group of terrace and
it's not just a Fukushima plant
equivalent of a meltdown nor is it a
Santa on own affray release of tritium
it can be a dump truck spill on the side
of the road it can be a recognition that
Manhattan Project or cold war area error
work had produced a profound amount of
contamination of soil it could be
fracking and the release of
radioisotopes into groundwater systems
it could be a whole host of things and
so as a result we have failed to learn
these lessons so far that we're all down
wind that we need transparency
accountability and real efforts that
report repair restore and ensure never
again and we need to keep asking these
questions of who's doing the science
addressing what questions according to
what notions of significance and what
data sets who is served by science now I
gave you a whole lot of information on a
whole lot of different topics and so
these are some of the ways that you can
go get more info on my math on my
methods and praxis especially on
methodologies this the the top article
there but these couple of books here are
very deep in
not only the Marshall Islands case but
but globally the cold works grants week
in in terms of China and week in terms
of France but strong on everybody else
this document just came out at the
humanitarian impacts of nuclear weapons
UN conference in Oslo last March did you
hear about it first one ever no wasn't
reported really in the US press but this
is accessible online similarly I give
you a couple of commentaries in part
because these these are very influential
I think of my publications and when you
think of your strategies as a scholar
advocate citizen of my publications
which have had the most impact in terms
of readership it's doing op-eds for
counterpunch with embedded links and
they get reprinted I did one op-ed where
I you know Google search before i posted
it and then the next day google search
to see just how many times had my title
been reproduced and thus was on other
people's blogs or reprinted in
newspapers around the world and it was
12,000 times overnight now when you
publish a book as an academic scholarly
Yale graduate what are you going to get
well if you're lucky you'll get 2,000
copies sold maybe that's generally the
print run in a hard copy press so you
know it's it's a very different notion
of getting your information out there at
having an influence on voice but also
these these two links here for the
United Nations give you how to you if
you want to see the Special Rapporteurs
report this is where you would go if you
want to see what is going on right now
in the world on the EPA permissibility
levels and the critical comments of it
that's where you go and as I said if you
want to copy of this stuff please Sadie
will help you with that so thank you
very much that's my overview
you